herzlich willkommen zu meinem neuen
format im kreis sei einfacher als
persönlicher kopf ich habe heute einen
ganz besonderen jahres vielleicht werd
ich weiß du bist hinterseite ich komme
heute einen tag lang für jahre vom
gewitter kopf dass ich weiß ihr werdet
heute sehen was jan so gerne ist wenn du
deine leide speisen zubereiten und trist
einst selber dafür überlegt ich komme ja
wahrscheinlich fragwürdig und erich das
frühstück ist lebe ja auch wenn du
kannst jede mahlzeit dann mit bis zu
zehn punkten es gibt echt benedikt also
pochiertes ei erhalte damit die sauce
hollandaise last und abgaben also genau
wie gewünscht hast und dazu cappuccino
das macchiato und anlassen verkehrt
machen also das geht so gehe ich erkläre
ganz kurz was mache ich habe hier einen
topf ausgestellt wird ein bisschen
wasser da eigentlich weiwei gefiel es
ist ganz eindeutig die eier auch keine
sorgen und schmeckt aber liegt nicht an
uns ist komplett neue trag ich helfe dir
solche rein gemacht das muss ich schon
mal hier so ein toastbrot auch die so
toll ist dass herr nickel hauptstory
leute die wirklich hoch sind würden sich
jetzt dafür verprügelt als ich hätte
selber gemacht wie gerne das
ja ich habe ja auch überlegt dass ich
wahrscheinlich auch zu manchen gästen
einfach nach hause und mir irgendwann
seit jahren hat sie gesagt und keine
küche deshalb das ganze nicht an sicher
dass dort auch eine gute idee dass man
dann auch für euch zu hause sehen kann
wie die leute die durch schüsse auf sie
genau was los ist und mir auf jeden fall
machbar lautet eine zweite feuerwehr
weiß ja nicht mal visitenkarten steht ja
das coolste ich werde das was eigentlich
brauche eigentlich andere hätte die
klinik aber das beste ist man diesen
kern heraus holt also einmal beim packen
können dann raus bringt dass er mehr
schwer aus jetzt hat sich schon mal
gelohnt ist echt mega ein frühstück das
schwere ist vielleicht etwas ändert wird
das verschieben heißt dass man die asche
legen die bank fast das mache ich auch
beim koch nach so geschliffen wirklich
die zeit ist verwischt
man muss hier so einen strudel machen
dann schüttet man die aufgeschlagene
eier in den strudel von durch diesen
kreislauf bleibt das eiweiß und das
klappt so dass das gleiche weise und das
eigelb bleibt zusammen
was also quasi das muskel trust
ermittelt genutzt heute gar nicht
kommentieren für mittag waren dass man
mir auch schon ziemlich gute idee ist
uns auf jeden fall bleibt okay ich werde
noch ganz kurz von der avocado creme
einfach drauf machen und jetzt würde
seinen weg lacht von markus minten film
ich mag die
sehr gut ja ich liebe aber karneval so
einfach wie die aber kein problem das
ganze ein bisschen mit einer gabel
zerdrücken zwei treffer und dann ist das
eigentlich auch schon fertig der zeuge
jetzt hier mal den strudel und werde
dann die eier von tieren eingeben und
los geht's
ich gebe es zu ich bin kein meister
interessiert und ich habe es einmal
versucht gestern abend weil ich dachte
irgendwann zehn minuten und es ging echt
in die hose okay das wird sehr
beschränken
ein traum
jetzt wollen wir die einmarschierten
das sieht doch ganz schön aus dann läuft
hier so wenn du machst ist leicht
gepfeffert er hat es irgendwie kommt das
nein der bibelforscher mit ok an da ist
es dein frühstück also dafür dass ich
dir einfach nur gesagt habe dass ich
irgendwas mit avocado und max möchte
hast du dir etwas maigret bis ausgedacht
dass ich bin sehr gespannt schmeckten
schreibt das hat voreingenommen bin ich
gespannt
das ist mir sehr lange die kammer pause
haben wir sehr lange überlebenszeit aber
würde ich entlassen
schnecken ist ja das freut mich sehr
super zu starten
ja ich habe es werden meine schuld ich
halte ich habe bei meinen körper weg
gelassen immerhin da wurde ja schon
nachgeholfen und campe nicht leid da
fehlt er hat gar wir sehen wirst
aufgegessen aufgedruckt nicht überredet
nicht gleich was sagst du wärest ihr
geschmeckt jetzt wahrlich nicht wenn du
jetzt mal drüber nach links entfernen
ist skala von 1 bis 10 - drei männer
gibt - 37 und kannst noch aufholen was
gibt mir an
also ich hab echt super und dachte dass
du das auch so schnell hinbekommen hast
wie das frühstück würde ich die
tatsächlich ein segen geben direkt mit
zehn leute das ist sehr gut jetzt muss
ich mich umso mehr über mittagessen ins
zeug legen wir springen direkt vom
mittagessen los geht's zum mittagessen
hat sich jahren von mir etwas mit
makkaroni gewünscht ich habe ein
bisschen nachgelassen dafür mir
spaghetti carbonara als makkaroni
carbonare richtig gute idee weil das
habe ich vor lange nicht gemacht und
guckt euch an ich habe die frischen
zutaten besorgt der kollege roman habe
ich gerade eben frisch gerieben dann
habe ich hier pancetta 300 gramm und
zehn eigelb ihr fragt euch vielleicht
was sind das für mengen wie vier jahren
essen die sache ist im wird auch da
seien und außerdem essig mit dave und
sebastian essen zu fünft dementsprechend
ist die relativ viel anstatt die harte
kruste von bräuchen habe ich auch dazu
gegeben die lassen wir nämlich aus in
der pfanne so dass der geschmack
trotzdem abgegeben wird auch sie mit es
am ende nochmal raus fischen ansonsten
müssen wir gleich einfach die ukraine
zusammen mit dem eigelb das ist die soße
von kanada ist wirklich so also dass das
einzige was rechen pfanne kommt der rest
bleibt quasi kalt und kommt am ende nur
auf die fertigung nun genau das ist
jetzt eine sehr ordentliche portionen
factory na also
180 daran habe auch das ist auch was
drauf personalrat italienischen flächen
zugeschaut
das ist höchst verbot ist sahen zu
benutzen kleine karawane benutzt wird in
italien tödlich gesäß schon ist ein
traum aber es ist ein absoluter traum
das lassen wir jetzt kurz stehen geben
warum ist das casting ist ich hätte es
mir auch gedacht hat mir mal gesagt wir
machen den körper gesagt kann es nicht
aber man muss sich wirklich alle bundes-
und youtube das kind entfernt kannst du
dich nach machen ist einfach nur ein tag
ist persönlicher kork und sind dann
könnt ihr das ja mal wird es auch immer
problemlos firma mitteilt wollte jemand
ein problem das ist wirklich ein traum
dass ich mal die krone sind trend und am
kochen ordentliche portion auf jeden
fall
das heißt wir machen jetzt auch hier
dringend weiter und geben den restlichen
speckt die restlichen pancetta bei den
fans sein wollte sagt han jia und mit
bauchspeck und das lassen wir jetzt auch
ein klein bisschen von dem nudelwasser
wir irgendwie soße hinein bleibt ein
bisschen mehr vermischen das ganze also
wird hier schön cremig man sieht finde
ich direkt an es ist ein bisschen so ein
bisschen milch dazugeben jetzt frisch
vermerkt ist auf das viele wasser was
die seiten wird kommt überhaupt gar kein
seiten das gericht sein weil die von
chatter hat super viel salz drin
hiermit spreche aber wir das gar nicht
das ist jetzt kommt jetzt der hinten
sind wir jetzt hier drücken weil die
teile raus wir nicht verwenden wollen
durch schütte jetzt die nudeln
vielleicht auch nicht kann aber das
nudelwasser zum trotz auch braucht das
für mich noch meine sonst nur abschicken
das ist echt ne ordentliche portion er
ist bei den us open ist kann das ist mit
forschen und will jetzt auch zu es wird
ja jetzt ist ganz wichtig ab diesem
zeitpunkt gibt es keine hitze mehr
kriegen sie nicht mehr es irgendwo auf
der welt also alle herdplatten aus wird
denn das ganze und ihres nächsten
kleines momentchen warten dass ich das
ganze ab geküsst hat 3 wenn wir die
carbonara jetzt auch hingegen berührt es
passt ein bisschen zufolge fahne aber
wir gehen jetzt haben aber so drüber und
gleich mischen wir das ganze schön durch
und dann wir müssen anfangen einfach mit
dem spendengeld in den fünf minuten im
auto stellt mir vorstellen dass man
womöglich sehr und das passend weil mac
entschied es ist ja im prinzip eine sehr
italienische variation von mac entschied
könnt ihr das auch per smartphone
flecken also fahren wir heute morgen
hier gegessen haben und jetzt bei jan
jantz streaming termin und stimme
sprechen mutter ist wir sind ok perfekt
als ausgleich für mich
in diesen 30 jahren ziemlich verlegen
die könnt ihr euch an lassen wenn ihr
wollt ich weiß nicht wie es aussieht
nachdem ich hier transportiert habe aber
das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
gestoppt da durch das ist transportiert
habe jetzt kann ich mich herzlich ein
mit dem parkplatz das leicht zu sagen
hier ist noch ein bisschen was übrig das
führt er wollte eigentlich auch dabei
sind jetzt erst die ganze unsere akkus
richtig ist aber bei meiner mutter zu
hause und dies gerade auf der arbeit und
der stadt enger freund von meiner mutter
den ersatzschlüssel gewollt und
architektur nicht auszuschließen
euro geht hier noch ein bisschen amüsant
kriegen wenn das essen
er kann auf jeden fall besser fällt als
deine alte na dann würde ich sagen ja
probiere gerne mal heute morgen 10 von
10 was wird es beim mittagessen
gisela ist er wissen wer bei minus 3
also besser geworden ich meckere
schmeckt aber wird das freut mich und
dann lassen wir sind zwar schmecken und
kommen dann gleich zum rating okay das
war das mittagessen jan erste gespräche
ich fand's super ja jetzt sehr sehr gut
schmeckt folgen wie hast du so kocht
volles jahr davon dass ich würde dir
tatsächlich geht deswegen eben wirklich
guten einem wirklich gehört tatsächlich
dann haben wir 20 von 20 bis er das ist
eine heftige strafe für das format also
ich bin gespannt ob ich die anderen
gäste auch so beeindrucken kann
es freut mich sehr dass es hier so gut
geschmeckt hat so leute kommen ja auch
schon zumachen essen ich habe ihn
wirklich fest vorgenommen jahren auch
mit dem abendessen noch vollkommen zu
überzeugen und ihr seht hier ist es jede
menge zweikampfstark wir machen wenn ich
eine lasagne ich habe ja schon wieder
seine gemacht haben aber ein richtig
geiles rezepten von josua weiß heinz der
dafür muss sich hier eine möhre
stable sellerie und eine zwiebel klein
würfeln 800 gramm hackfleisch im staat
nicht und schweinen gemischt und ich
muss meinen weg bleibt das video haben
wir schon ein bisschen fleisch dafür
lägen jetzt einfach ein bisschen oliven
geben dass wir diesen riesen topf 1 der
bereits sehr alt ist
[Musik]
deshalb hat vielleicht ein bisschen halt
nicht verstehen ich habe jetzt hat die
panzer gestimmt und werdet ihr in den
topf geben der von der hitze runter ist
noch aber ihr seht schon während immer
noch full power mit pancetta genau wie
das kag fleisch wenn jetzt einmal schön
anbraten von beiden seiten für das
script braucht mitteilt auch die hohe
hitze gewählt weil es soll schon heiß
sein aber es weiß hätte ich ein bisschen
sehr direkt ab hier also der und die
sache ist wir haben jetzt gerade erst 17
uhr geplanten 20 uhr zu essen aber die
tomatensoße soll einfach zwei stunden
im herbst stehen und köchen die man
sprechen müssen wir das ganze jetzt
schon was ich bin auch sehr stolz wenn
ich das so sagen zwei stunden verlässt
ist schon länger so geht das ganz schön
angebrachten einmal holt jetzt mal raus
und geben dann hat unser gemüse in den
kopf hinein in deutschland wenn man so
einen bunten pop hat dann weiß man dass
es lecker wird
drei esslöffel formaten heute also schon
ordentlich ein großes repertoire tag und
3 lasst uns den spaß mit 240 liter
weißwein ablöschen
wir warten jetzt kurz bis sich der
beschwerden um ungefähr die hälfte vom
volumen reduziert hat dann gehen wir
jetzt zusätzlich als flüssigkeit noch
einmal 340 meter hüne aufgelöst
verbrauchen und das ist auch so ein
bisschen die saucen basis und ihr seht
es ist sehr flüssig also es kommen
natürlich gleich fleisch und martin aber
deshalb könnte das ganze dann halt auch
zwei stunden vor sich in wels muss ja
irgendwo hält hitzfeld geht raus der
geschmack noch drin dass man diesen
themen die geschmacks einheit pro
kubikzentimeter soße kommen die tomaten
und jetzt gehen mir das ganze vielleicht
wieder zurück
dann würde ich sagen wünsche ich dem
fleisch viel spaß
zwei stunden lang hat das ganze jetzt
gefällte leute ich weiß wir haben zu
erkennen aber es ist glaube ich deutlich
weniger frauen auf jeden fall ist es
jetzt so richtig ratsch und schmeckt
übertrieben geister dass man probiert
speisen wie lasagne platten kurz rein
ich bereite schon mal hier büffel
mozzarella vor
also es ist auf jeden fall eine lange
gericht also schon sehr edel
büffelmozzarella wir arbeiten auch
gleich mit parmaschinken auch ja im
nächsten schritt muss ich eigentlich nur
noch die lasagne belegen dann geht das
ganze keine stunde in den ofen
allein was hier für eine menge tanz dach
ist und leute guckt da mal rein es ist
echt will nummer muss ich sagen ich
würde das ganze zwar sind die ganze
flüssigkeit raus und es duftet wirklich
ganz wild läge hier den boden von der
auflaufform mal aus mit dem mietshaus
alles so standen die an gewalt platte
komplettiert drüber passende drei
stücken eine reihe erst das heißt dass
nacheinander geht wenn man muss einfach
papst alle küchen und die kranke feuer
resistente händler wie das gefühl genau
der mit so eine basis auf die bahn
ein bisschen recorder verteilen den so
ein bisschen fest gleich verstreichen
braucht ihre konter geben jetzt ein
bisschen paar blätter frischem basilikum
habe ich gerade von meinem basilikum
pflanzte abgeschnitten nicht allzuviel
geheimnis mit parmaschinken einfach so
12 scheiben ja auch nicht super viel ich
glaube das gibt noch mal einen sehr
intensiven geschmack hier rein weil
jetzt ein wenig von dem kapital und
meinte natürlich viel sagen das sehr gut
darauf kommt jetzt was man unsere würfel
nutzer wälder neue data recorder teil
jetzt wieder ein bisschen basilikum
abschminken wird jetzt kommt noch zum
schluss eine lage aber nur von der soße
obendrauf eine großzügige lage auf jeden
fall und die toppen wir dann mit
unmengen an käse freunde
es muss ja auch so gysi sein dass musik
und misst das ist soweit das ist
wirklich schwer also das ist eine ganze
menge und es sieht auch gut aus in so
einem produkt shooting irgendwie würde
so alles irgendwie sind danach ist
angekommen wie lasagne steht hier ist
auch eingetroffen geboten gefeilt und
widersetzen
also ich glaube es wird nicht sehr gut
schneiden nicht einen echten bis
überhaupt auf der welt gesehen ich sie
gemacht haben und es wieder erstklassig
jeder bei echten
da würde sich das euch einfach
irgendwann probierte tomaten discos und
andachten die theorie dass diese darüber
wird das ist überall landen gibt haben
überlebt weil nicht so sehr gespannt was
ihr das gesagt ich brauche ja ja ja
passt geil die kommen weitere gut wie
fertig gepflastert von jahren treffen
dafür lobt mich sehr wenn ich schon so
bekommen keine großen markt
okay lasst euch schmecken wir kommen
nicht wieder zum finalen rating und ich
bin sehr gespannt ob aufgegessen hier
ist es üblich hat es euch geschmeckt
vorsemester mega gut also zum alten
eisen nicht neu packen weil hier abstand
am besten schmeckt echt das heißt um
platz 10 auf jeden fall 10
das find ich habe bei beiden gerichten
schon zehn fonds er ich wollte das
einfach 30 aus 30 punkten müssen
ich würde sagen dass war ein würdiger
start für das format ist der rechtsplan
marie die einbetten der es nicht so
leicht zu dir passt nicht mitreden ist
tatsächlich so auch schon in folge glück
haben also solltet ihr noch nicht mal ob
du ein mann bist du schon bist du nicht
siehst